FRIENDS.
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ WE START TONIGHT WITH A
CLINTON VERY WORRIED
TOP AIDES HANDLED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION INCLUDING
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW MUCH
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
PASSED THROUGH HER UNSECURE
SERVER.
WHO PUT THE INFORMATION ONTO
THE SERVER?
WHICH INVESTIGATORS KNEW
ABOUT ALL OF THIS AND WHEN
DID THEY KNOW ABOUT THIS?
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, JOHN
SOLOMON WHO WILL JOIN US
FROM THE HILL REPORTING THAT
TRYING TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT ANY PAY FOR PLAY
SECRETARY OF STATE.
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING AND I
HAVE BEEN SAYING ON THIS
PROGRAM 2018 WILL BE THE
YEAR THAT ALL OF THESE
SCANDALS BOOMERANG BACK ON
THE LEFT, THE MEDIA, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND TONIGHT
IT'S ALL BEGINNING TO
UNFOLD.
FOR EXAMPLE, TAKE TONIGHT'S
NEW INFORMATION ABOUT THE
LOOKING INTO THE URANIUM ONE
GIVE HOUSE INVESTIGATORS
WITNESSES IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION AND THE
DOSSIER INVESTIGATION.
NOW, ALL THIS MEANS, ALL
THIS INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CLINTON, BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA, THAT
FAKE NEWS SALACIOUS DOSSIER,
RUSSIAN DOSSIER WILL FINALLY
NOW SEE THE LIGHT OF DAY.
YOU HAVE GOT TO BUCKLE UP.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE WILL GET
BACK TO THAT IN A MINUTE.
MEDIA AND THEIR GIANT, WELL,
INCESTUOUS ALMOST LIKE
BUBBLE, WELL THEN YOU MIGHT
HAVE SEEN THAT THE ECONOMY
GOOD NEWS FOR FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS DOW
JONES SOARED TO 25,000
HIGHEST NUMBER EVER.
JOB MARKET CONTINUES TO
OBAMA.
ADP REPORTING 250,000 NEW
JOBS CREATED IN DECEMBER
ALONE WHICH IS THE MOST IN
NINE MONTHS FOR THAT SURVEY.
AND TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
HEADLINE.
JOB CUT ANNOUNCEMENTS IN
2017 SEE THE LOWEST LEVEL
SINCE 1990, CHALLENGER
HEADLINE.
MANUFACTURING IN THE U.S.
JUST ACCELERATED TO ITS BEST
YEAR SINCE 2004.
AND EARLIER TODAY, THE
PRESIDENT IS MOVING TO NOW
OPEN UP OFFSHORE DRILLING,
THAT'S RIGHT, OFF THE COAST,
BOTH COASTS AND IN THE GULF,
WHICH IS VITAL TO AMERICA
BECOMING ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
THE LIFE BLOOD OF OUR
ECONOMY.
AND THAT'S JUST ONLY SOME OF
THE GOOD NEWS FROM THIS WEEK
ALONE.
UNEMPLOYMENT, A 17-YEAR LOW.
BEFORE THE 250,000 JOBS,
1.7 MILLION JOBS WERE
CREATED.
UNEMPLOYMENT IN AMERICA IS
NOW AT A 17-YEAR LOW.
FOOD STAMP USE IS AT 7-YEAR
LOW.
2 MILLION FEWER PEOPLE USING
FOOD STAMPS NOW UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN ONE YEAR.
HOME PRICES ARE UP 6%.
BURDENSOME REGULATION FROM
OUR GOVERNMENT AND FOR EVERY
NEW ONE THEY CREATED, IN
TERMS OF REGULATION, 16 HAVE
BEEN SLASHED AND CUT AWAY.
THERE IS G.D.P. SO FAR WE
HAVE SEEN TWO QUARTERS OF
OVER 3% GROWTH.
AND, REMEMBER, BARACK OBAMA,
THE ONLY PRESIDENT IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY TO
NEVER REACH 3% G.D.P. GROWTH
FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR.
NOW, HERE'S WHAT THE MEDIA
WILL NEVER TELL YOU.
WELL, THERE IS A NIGHT AND
DAY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
ECONOMY JUST A YEAR AGO AND
NOW UNDER DONALD TRUMP FOR
ONE YEAR.
UNDER OBAMA'S ECONOMY I WILL
REMIND YOU IT WAS GOD-AWFUL.
LOWEST PARTICIPATION RATED
SINCE THE 1970S, 95 MILLION
AMERICANS OUT OF THE LABOR
FORCE.
THE WORST ECONOMIC RECOVERY
SINCE THE 1940S, THE LOWEST
HOME OWNERSHIP RATE IN 51
YEARS.
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS.
8 MILLION MORE ON POVERTY.
43 MILLION TOTAL LIVING IN
POVERTY UNDER OBAMA IN JUST
ONE YEAR THE ECONOMY IS NOW
ALL GOOD NEWS FOR US.
LIBERALS, THE MEDIA, THEY
SAID OH, THE TAX CUTS ARE
GOING TO BE TERRIBLE FOR THE
ECONOMY.
IT'S ONLY GOING TO BENEFIT
CORPORATIONS.
BY THE WAY, CORPORATIONS
DON'T PAY TAXES.
TURNS OUT TO BE A BIG FAT
LIE.
THEY PASS THE COST ON TO US.
COMPANIES LIKE, LOOK, BANK
OF AMERICA, WELLS FARGO,
U.S. BANK, SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES AND OTHERS,
AMERICAN AIRLINES, FIFTH
THIRD BANK, EVEN COMCAST,
THE PARENT COMPANY OF
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC WOW,
$1,000 BONUSES AND PAY
THEY WILL INVEST NOW
BILLIONS BACK INTO THE U.S.
ECONOMY.
BUILD FACTORIES AND
MANUFACTURING CENTERS AND
HIRE NEW EMPLOYEES, NOT TO
MENTION YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WILL SOON START TO
SEE MONEY IN YOUR PAYCHECKS
WHERE IT BELONGS.
IT'S ALL BECAUSE OF WHAT,
THIS TAX BILL THAT THE MEDIA
SAID WAS GOD-AWFUL.
IT JUST SHOWS YOU HOW
CLUELESS AND HOW THE MEDIA
LIES TO YOU DAILY AND
THEY HAVE THIS TRUMP-HATING
OBSESSION WHICH I TOLD YOU
ABOUT LAST NIGHT, WHICH
MEANS THAT THEY WILL DO AND
SAY ANYTHING TO TRY AND HURT
HIM ON A DAILY BASIS.
LET ME TELL YOU HOW IT
CNN, HE ACTUALLY CALLED THEM
A DEMENTED LIAR AND THEN
CONSPIRACY TV, NBC AS TO SAY
PATHOLOGICAL LIAR AND THEY
TALK TO EACH OTHER.
BUNCH OF SHEEP.
THEY ARE BRAIN-DEAD.
THEY ARE HYPNOTIZED AND LIKE
WATCHING A HORROR MOVIE
UNFOLD BEFORE OUR EYES.
REMEMBER, ONLY DAYS AGO THE
MEDIA WANTED TO YOU BELIEVE
WE WERE ON THE VERGE OF
NUCLEAR WAR WITH NORTH
KOREA.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE UNLIKE HIS
PREDECESSORS, PRESIDENT
TRUMP REFUSED TO BE AN
APPEASER AND CAPITULATE TO
THE THREATS OF KIM JONG UN
COVERAGE AS THEY LIE TO YOU.
>> THE PRESIDENT ESSENTIALLY
DARING THE LEADER OF NUCLEAR
ARMED NORTH KOREA TONIGHT TO
PROVE THAT HIS BUTTON WORKS.
THIS IS OUR WORLD NOW.
>> 16 TWEETS TODAY TO START
THE NEW YEAR.
>> THESE ARE THE MESSAGES
FROM A PERSON WHO IS NOT
WELL FROM.
A LEADER WHO IS NOT FIT FOR
OFFICE.
>> TRUMP NEEDS TO BE
MEDICATED AND HOSPITALIZED.
[LAUGHTER]
AT THIS POINT OR HE IS GOING
NORTH KOREA AND THE NUCLEAR
BUTTON THE SIZE OF THE
NUCLEAR BUTTON THAT HAS
RAISED ALARM BELLS NOT JUST
>> Sean: THAT FRENZY
DISPLAYED WAS TWO DAYS AGO
FROM THE MEDIA.
SARAH SANDERS SLAPPED DOWN
THE PRESS FOR ATTACKING THE
PRESIDENT.
GOOD FOR HER.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S MENTAL FITNESS
THAT HE APPEARS TO BE
SPEAKING SO LIGHTLY ABOUT
THREATS REGARDING NUCLEAR
BUTTONS?
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE MENTAL FITNESS OF THE
LEADER OF NORTH KOREA.
HE HAS MADE REPEATED
IS NOT GOING TO COWER DOWN
AND NOT GOING TO BE WEAK AND
IS GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE DOES WHAT HE HAS PROMISED
TO DO AND THAT'S STAND UP
AND PROTECT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: UNDERSTAND, 48
HOURS AGO YOUR MEDIA WAS
LOSING THEIR MINDS AND
PREDICTING OH, POTENTIAL
NUCLEAR FALLOUT.
THAT WAS, OF COURSE, UNTIL
STEVE BANNON'S COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
SHIFTS AWAY AND CHANGES AND
THE WORLD IS GOING TO END AT
ANY MINUTE AND THEN THEY
FIND A NEW BEST FRIEND.
THAT'S RIGHT, OH, LET'S SEE,
A GUY THEY HAVE HATED
FOREVER.
THEY HAVE UNCONTROLLABLE
GLEE THAT STEVE BANNON, A
GUY THAT THEY HATE, SAID
SOMETHING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
PATHETIC ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE.
NOW, LOOK AT HOW
BREATHLESSLY THEY ARE
SINGLE THING ABOUT THE HE
ECONOMY?
THAT'S GOOD?
ANYTHING THAT TRUMP HAS DONE
GOOD?
IF THE DOG BITES THE
WORLD IT'S ALL DONALD
TRUMP'S FAULT.
WATCH THIS.
>> NEW REVELATIONS FROM A
SOON TO BE PUBLISHED BOOK
ARE ROCKING THE TRUMP
TRUMP AS A VOLATILE AND
UNCONTROLLABLE FORCE WITHIN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ISSUED A
STATEMENT LIKE NO
PRESIDENTIAL STATEMENT EVER
BEFORE IN AMERICAN HISTORY
LAMBASTING HIS FORMER
CAMPAIGN AND WHITE HOUSE
SENIOR STRATEGIST STEVE
BANNON IN NO UNCERTAIN
TERMS.
>> NOW IT SEEMS BANNON HAS
TURNED ON HIS OLD BOSS.
BANNON ON THE RECORD SAYING
THINGS IMPLICATING HIM IN
THE RUSSIA PROBE AND IT
SUGGESTS TRUMP'S OLDEST SON
AND SON-IN-LAW COMMITTED
TREASON.
HAD THEIR ARMS AROUND AND
HAD THEIR THUMBS UP TAKING
PICTURE TWOS DAYS AGO NOW
STEVE BANNON IS TALKING
ABOUT TREASON.
MICHAEL WOLFF'S FIRE AND
FURY INSIDE THE TRUMP'S
WHITE HOUSE FEATURES
BLISTERING ATTACKS ON STEVE
BANNON.
EARLY DAYS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE IT HAS DRAWN A FURIOUS
RESPONSE FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> Sean: THIS IS HOW BAD IT
CNN, FAKE NEWS JAKE AT THAT
POINT PER AND WHAT HE USED
EARLIER TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
THE NEW MICHAEL WOLFF BOOK.
MENTAL FITNESS?
FOR FAKE NEWS JAKE.
HE HAS TO TAKE HIS MARCHING
ORDERS FROM HIS TRUMP-HATING
SOON TO BE SCANDALED PLAGUED
BOSS MATT SUCKER WHO IS
BOSS MATT ZUCKER WHO IS BEST
FRIENDS WITH MATT LAUER.
THEY WILL DRAG THIS OUT AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE UNTIL THE
NEXT CRISIS THEY CREATE
COMES ALONG.
IF IT'S NUCLEAR WAR COMING
TWO DAYS LATER THEY WILL
FORGET ABOUT IT.
COUNTRY.
UNPRECEDENTED.
BUFF YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN AN
EXTENSION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY FOR DECADES.
HERE'S THE PROOF.
THEY HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
BREATHLESS, HYSTERICAL
REPORTING BUT ONLY WHEN
CONSERVATIVES OR REPUBLICANS
ARE OCCUPYING THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THE MEDIA HAS ALSO BENT OVER
BACKWARDS TO PRAISE THE
PRESIDENTS THEY SO LOVE
ADORE AND WORSHIP LIKE BILL
CLINTON AND BARACK OBAMA.
PEOPLE THAT APPEASE
MURDERING DICTATORS AND
DESPOTS.
NOW, LET'S START WITH
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN.
THIS IS WHERE OUR HISTORY
LESSON BEGINS TONIGHT BACK
IN 1984.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER IT WAS A
ADDRESS OH, HE IS GOING TO
DESTROY RUSSIA WITH NEWARKS.
HE WAS JOKING, KEEP IN MIND
THIS WAS NEVER IN THE ACTUAL
REAL SPEECH.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> MY FELLOW AMERICANS, I'M
PLEASED TO TELL YOU TODAY
THAT I HAVE SIGNED
LEGISLATION THAT WILL OUTLAW
RUSSIA FOREVER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Sean: OF COURSE THE AUDIO
INTO A HUGE MASSIVE
INTERNATIONAL CRISIS EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS A JOKE.
>> IT WAS THE JOKE HEARD
AROUND THE WORLD, THE ONE BY
PRESIDENT REAGAN ABOUT
BOMBING THE SOVIET UNION AND
IT RESULTED IN A SOVIET RED
ALERT AND IT BECAME A
CAMPAIGN ISSUE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> BY AUGUST 14TH THE STORY
BECAME WORLD NEWS, A MAJOR
ITEM ON MOSCOW TELEVISION
WHERE THE JOKE WAS NOT
TREATED AS A LAUGHING
MATTER.
SEAN SEAN LOOK AT THIS
HEADLINE FROM THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" REAGAN'S GAS GAFFE
AND IT ONLY GETS WORSE FROM
THERE.
THE MEDIA COULDN'T STAND THE
FACT RONALD REAGAN ENDED UP
BY BEING STRONG, DEFEATING
THE SOVIET UNION AND HE
DIDN'T FIRE A SINGLE SHOT.
AND THAT STARTED WHEN RONALD
REAGAN CALLED THE COMMUNIST
REGIME WHAT IT REALLY WAS AN
EVIL EMPIRE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY PREACH THE SUPREMACY
PREDICT DOCUMENTATION OF ALL
PEOPLE ON THE WORK.
THEY ARE THE FOCUS OF EVIL
IN THE MODERN WORLD.
SO IN YOUR DISCUSSIONS OF
THE NUCLEAR FREEZE
PROPOSALS, I URGE YOU TO
BEWARE OF THE TEMPTATION OF
RIDE, THE TEMPTATION OF
LIVELY DECLARING YOURSELVES
ABOVE IT ALL AND LABEL SIDES
EQUALLY HAVE CALLED TO
IGNORE THE FACTS OF HISTORY
AND THE AGGRESSIVE IMPULSES
OF AN EVIL EMPIRE TO CALL
THE ARMS RACE A GIANT
MISUNDERSTANDING AND THEREBY
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE
STRUGGLE FROM RIGHT AND
WRONG AND GOOD AND EVIL.
SEAN SEAN HE DIDN'T GIVE
THEM BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
PRESIDENT REAGAN WAS
CONFRONTING EVIL IN HIS
TIME.
BUT THEN IT WAS WAY TOO MUCH
FOR THE MEDIA, THE LIBERAL
SEE BOWING AND KISSING RINGS
AND APPEASEMENT.
HERE'S A QUOTE FROM THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" DESCRIBING
REAGAN'S SPEECH, QUOTE:  IN
THE LONG RUN, HOWEVER, THE
PROCLAMATION OF HOLY WAR
AGAINST EVIL ELM PAIR.
TURNS OUT THE SO-CALLED
PAPER OF RECORD, JUST LIKE
THE REST OF THE LIBERAL
MEDIA WAS COMPLETELY WRONG.
IF MEDIA FOLLOWED THE ADVICE
THE SOVIET UNION MIGHT STILL
BE STANDING.
NEXT GEORGE W. BUSH HE
AXIS OF EVIL.
YOU MAY REMEMBER.
THIS NORTH KOREA IS A ARMING
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION
WHILE STARVING ITS CITIZENS.
IRAN AGGRESSIVELY PURSUES
THESE WEAPONS AND EXPORTS
TERROR WHILE AN UNELECTED
IRAQ CONTINUES TO FLAUNT ITS
HOSTILITY TOWARD AMERICA AND
TO SUPPORT TERROR.
THE IRAQI REGIME HAS PLOTTED
TO DEVELOP ANTHRAX AND NERVE
GAS AND NUCLEAR WEAPONS FOR
OVER A DECADE.
STATES LIKE THESE AND THEIR
TERRORISTS ALLIES CONSTITUTE
AN AXIS OF EVIL ARMING TO
THREATEN THE PEACE OF THE
WORLD.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE
IN THE LAST CENTURY OVER
100 MILLION HUMAN SOULS
DESTROYED.
IS THAT NOT EVIL?
HERE ARE SOME OF THE
HEADLINES AFTER GEORGE W.
BUSH'S SPEECH IMMEDIATELY
THEREAFTER.
RESPONSE TO TERROR HAS BUSH
OVERSTATED NORTH KOREAN
THREAT QUESTION MARK?
ALLIES HEAR SORROW NOTE AND
STILL ATTACKING BUSH'S
SPEECH.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
EXAMPLES FROM THE MEDIA
RESEARCH CENTER.
>> UP UNTIL THAT MOMENT,
IRAN WAS MORE OR LESS AN
AMERICAN ALLY BY BEING
INCLUDED IN THE AXIS OF
EVIL, IT TURNED THE IRANIAN
GOVERNMENT IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
IT WAS A TURNING POINT IN
AMERICAN POLITICS AND IN
FOREIGN POLICY.
>> WHEN KIM'S FATHER KIM
REINFORCED 50 YEARS LATER
WHEN THE U.S. LABELED NORTH
KOREA AXLES OF EVIL WITH
IRAN AND IRAQ.
KIM JONG UN ALWAYS FELT HE
WOULD BE NEXT AFTER IRAQ.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA
EVISCERATED PRESIDENT BUSH
BUT HE WAS RIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK AT IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA TODAY.
CONFRONTED HEAD ON AND AS
FOR THE MEDIA, WELL, THEY
CAN'T STAND THE KIND OF
TOUGH AND DIRECT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT AMERICA
DOES HAVE ENEMIES, THAT
THERE IS EVIL IN OUR TIME.
AND APPARENTLY THEY WOULD
RATHER THEIR PRESIDENTS
BENDING DOWN AND KISSING THE
RINGS AND BOWING AND KISSING
THE FEET OF MURDERING
DICTATORS.
UN'S FATHER KIM JONG IL AND
GIVING BILLIONS OF ENERGY
SUBSIDIES ALLOWING NORTH
KOREA TO KEEP THEIR NUCLEAR
FUEL RODS AND THEN GOES ON
TV AND TELLS YOU THIS IS A
GREAT DEAL FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHAT A LIE THAT WAS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS A GOOD DEAL FOR
THE UNITED STATES.
NORTH KOREA WILL FREEZE AND
SOUTH KOREA AND OUR OTHER
ALLIES WILL BE BETTER
SAFER AS WE SLOW THE SPREAD
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
SOUTH KOREA WITH SUPPORT
FROM JAPAN AND OTHER NATIONS
WILL BEAR MOST OF THE COST
OF PROVIDING NORTH KOREA
WITH FUEL TO MAKE UP FOR THE
NUCLEAR ENERGY IT IS LOSING.
AND THEY WILL PAY FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE POWER SYSTEM FOR
WHILE MAKING IT MUCH HARDER
FOR THEM TO PRODUCE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
THE UNITED STATES AND
INTERNATIONAL INSPECTOR ALSO
CAREFULLY MONITOR NORTH
KOREA TO MAKE SURE IT KEEPS
ITS COMMITMENTS.
ONLY AS IT DOES SO, WILL
NORTH KOREA FULLY JOIN THE
COMMUNITY OF NATIONS.
>> Sean: TODAY WE KNOW HIS
BRIBERY OR ATTEMPTED BRIBERY
FLAWS BACK THEN WITH THE
DEAL WITH NORTH KOREA, THE
MEDIA PRAISED BILL CLINTON'S
EFFORTS.
>> THE DEAL THAT COULD END
WEAPONS.
IT COULD ALSO EASE TENSIONS
ON THE KOREAN PENINSULA AND
OPEN THE WAY FOR NORMAL
RELATIONS BETWEEN THE U.S.
AND ONE OF THE WORLD'S LAST
OLD LINE HARD LINE COMMUNIST
STATES.
>> BEYOND THE DETAILS NORTH
KOREA SEEMS TO HAVE MADE
FUNDAMENTAL DECISION THAT
THE COLD WAR IS REALLY OVER.
>> CRUCIAL INSPECTIONS ARE
IS IMPLEMENTED.
AMERICAN OFFICIALS SAY THE
DELAY IS A SMALL PRICE TO
PAY FOR GETTING NORTH KOREA
TO SHUTT DOWN ITS ENTIRE
NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> Sean: YOU WOULD THINK THE
MEDIA WOULD LEARN LESSONS OF
HISTORY BUT THEY DIDN'T
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL A BUNCH
OF BRAIN DEAD SHEEP WITH AN
AGENDA.
PRESIDENT OBAMA PROUDLY
ANNOUNCING A NUCLEAR DEAL
US, WIPE US OFF THE FACE OF
THE EARTH ALONG WITH ISRAEL.
WATCH THIS.
>> TODAY, AFTER TWO YEARS OF
NEGOTIATIONS, THE UNITED
STATES, TOGETHER WITH OUR
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS, HAS
ACHIEVED SOMETHING THAT
DECADES OF ANIMOSITY HAS
NOT.
AL COMPREHENSIVE LONG-TERM
DEAL WITH IRAN THAT WILL
PREVENT IT FROM OBTAINING A
NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THIS DEAL DEMONSTRATES THAT
CHANGE.
CHANGE THAT MAKES OUR
>> Sean: TOTAL B.S., TOTAL
STUPIDITY.
AND WHAT OBAMA FORGOT TO
MENTION OH, HE GAVE THE
RADICAL MULLAHS THAT ARE
SAYING AND CHANTING DEATH TO
AMERICA IN IRAN HE GAVE THEM
150 BILLION OF YOUR DOLLARS.
PLANE LOADS OF CASH AND
OTHER CURRENCIES.
AND TEHRAN, THEY ARE STILL
ALLOWED TO KEEP AND SPEND
THEIR CENTRIFUGES WHICH PUTS
THEM ON THE PATH TOWARDS
BUILDING A NUCLEAR WEAPON
ONCE THE DEAL RUNS OUT JUST
LIKE NORTH KOREA.
THE MEDIA DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
ANY OF THIS.
THEY WERE QUICK TO HEAP
PRAISE ON OBAMA, THE
PEACE-PRIZE WINNER.
>> THE U.S. AND WORLD POWERS
OUR BIGGEST RIVALS FROM
DELIVER A STATEMENT ON THIS
THIS AGREEMENT IS SUPPOSED
>> HAS THE U.S. AND ITS
ALLIES SUCCESSFULLY BLOCKED
IRAN FROM MAKING A NUCLEAR
BOMB, AT LEAST FOR NOW?
>> BUT TONIGHT THE UNITED
STATES COULD BE ENTERING A
NEW ERA IN ITS RELATIONSHIP
WITH IRAN.
>> I THINK IT BEGINS TO
CHANGE THE DYNAMICS OF A
TEHRAN.
I THINK THE DEAL PROVIDES
MORE THAN THE UNITED STATES
ANTICIPATED AND I THINK IT
COULD HELP PREVENT AN ARMS
RACE IN THE REGION THAT
WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO NOT
JUST THE MIDDLE EAST BUT TO
THE WHOLE WORLD.
>> Sean: THAT'S TONIGHT'S
HANNITY HISTORY LESSON IT
PERSONIFIES YOUR MEDIA IN
THIS COUNTRY FOR WHO THEY
ARE.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF STRONG
LEADERS THAT DARE TO
CAPITULATION AND APPEASEMENT
EVEN THOUGH IT FAILS EVERY
SINGLE TIME.
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO KNOW
HOW THE MEDIA WANTS A
PRESIDENT TO BEHAVE ON THE
WORLD STAGE, THEN TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS PICTURE.
TAKE A LOOK, RIGHT THERE.
OH, YEAH.
SO WHAT DOES OUR HISTORY
LESSON PROVE IN THE MEDIA
HAS BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE MINDLESS LIBERAL LEFT
WING RADICAL IDEALOGUES THAT
NO LONGER REPORT THE TRUTH.
THEY MIGHT ONLY LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IF HE SUCKED
UP TO, WHAT, RADICAL MULLAHS